are you ready to rule the world thank
you the French Revolution is one of the
most brutal and tumultuous periods in
recent history and yet it helped lay the
very foundations of the modern world at
the center of unity lies are known our
deadliest assassin yet you'll experience
a revolution through his eyes build up
your own skill set an arsenal to suit
your own unique play style and approach
Assassin's Creed unity takes the
franchise the unprecedented territory
earlier today we introduced the four
player shared experience but in addition
for this novel way of playing the game
we've completely redesigned the
fundamental building blocks of the core
experience itself unity is about carving
your own unique path to a huge immersive
city filled with countless stories
activities and rewards here's a small
face of our systemic open-world play by
Dominic Butler lead level designer on
Assassin's Creed unity
poor France is ill and our city is a
wound inflamed by all efforts to heal
her a king once ruled headstrong and
corrupt now headless and a corpse
murdered by men just as vile
today fanatics from all sides spill
blood on every corner
a thousand terrors I mean to cure day by
day street by street Templar by Templar
I think the gods
miss Jenny
I can't
they're up I will return to see justice
done every faction carries its own -
can't solve everything
here's the spot I'm not too late
catch captain's ever made his dinner
questions
the Machine executions soon enough
you've skittish weight and I'm not
afraid to say it's mr. Tarrou they're
sending out today a man with shady
friends with the jacobeans don't act
quick it's their own lives that we lose
it say none I understand you well
it wasn't me
I'm not the man you're after good where
is he
but this is this the executions good you
should leave this place
yes'm sure Nessie Nessie
yeah
Robespierre studies more than enough to
slow him down
such a soon
stand aside or face immediate
imprisonment
before the
Pete